hey what's up guys my name is Jono and
welcome to another episode of a lot of
their tips today we will be talking
about programming languages so which
programming languages should you choose
essentially for doing love and death so
let's talk about this so first of all we
have procedural programming languages
right and the most popular example here
is C and procedural programming language
of course is a basically non
object-oriented programming languages
language right so like in a procedural
language you just write your code you
just write your functions and you don't
have anything like classes or instances
or objects so there are a few problems
with procedural programming languages as
far as something like litem dad goes
right first of all they are fast and
efficient right that's obviously no
downside but they are fast and efficient
that's kind of an upside here however
are see in particularly is very slow to
development without libraries right so
in other words if you want to make a
window it's not easy right you have to
basically I wouldn't even considered
doing pure C for anything outside of a
lot of there not to mention inside a lot
and there is just really really slow it
is basically the definition of writing
things from scratch okay
learning stuff like assembly and
freaking binary whatever and for masses
of codes for example so obviously if
you're making a game you're going to be
coding a lot that's going to give you a
bad time and the reason is it's really
really hard to organize your code in C
okay you don't have things like classes
so if you don't have like concepts like
inheritance polymorphism you know all of
that stuff you don't have any of that
you're a hat you can't really make like
an entity a superclass of we can't do
that stuff right you have to work around
that kind of thing okay that is a bit of
a problem because it makes it really
hard to organize your code and again if
you are trying to make a game in 48
hours you don't want to really be
thinking about hang on a minute did I
did I do this function already is this
accessing it's just accessing another
function my file is really big now is
like a thousand lines of code in one
file I should split this up blah blah
blah etc alright it's just hard really
hard to organize now the alternative is
our object are any programming languages
now this includes languages like C++
Java C sharp what
right now this is much more practical
for video game development okay and the
reason is the way the video games are
typically structured nowadays is you
have a lot of inheritance happening you
have these objects you have these these
these instances happening okay and that
makes it much more suitable for making
games not just and love them there but
pretty much everywhere around the world
right everywhere in not around the world
will ya around the world but in pretty
much any any like well in life I mean it
makes it just much more practical for
game development because the way the
games are structured objects are just
convenient very convenient for game
development okay
it is around the same speed as
procedural so if you're wondering about
performance issues you shouldn't be
really because um I mean it is it is it
there is some difference on some systems
I actually did a massive research report
about this essentially there's no
difference okay it's about the same
now most these languages also happen to
have suitable libraries okay and by that
I mean attached libraries as well as
access to libraries okay so for example
writes C++ has libraries for has sorry
has classes and and objects for Strings
and for dynamic arrays C doesn't have
any of that stuff okay Java has an
excellent graphical API which will go
onto in a minute
simplify or C doesn't have that stuff so
you have a lot more content a lot more
support for these kind of languages
which is much better now let's talk
about C++ okay why should you or should
you use C++ in lot um dere
first of all it's a native language okay
what does that mean that means that when
you run something on your computer is
going to natively run that okay on work
whether that be Windows Mac whatever it
is native okay you write code you
compile the code once you compile the
code you run your application that
application communicates directly to the
CPU okay
directly that's very good for
performance mind you now they're all
there for C++ or solid a number of
libraries available including STL GL f
WS F
allegro I've actually never used as a SF
ml or Allegro but I've heard good things
about them STL is brilliant so is gel fw
there are a lot of engines available ear
lift and ogre engines of one of the most
popular ones but because of these
libraries that are available you could
always make your own engine in a
suitable amount of time talking like
maybe like four hours okay you could
definitely like I'm talking like sound
everything maybe even a bit of 3d done
in about four hours because of these
awesome libraries like STL & GL fw ok
which is which is great okay so the
development time isn't too slow now
unfortunately there's no web browser
compatibility natively I know there are
very very slim little really kind of
slower not really awesome ways of
getting sample spots to run in a web
browser I am aware of that right but
natively there is no web browser
compatibility now that's a problem
that's a bit of a problem to me and the
reason that's a bit of a problem to me
is when people are looking at your games
in lot um dare right they want it they
probably like downloading a game isn't
going to be well it's going to take too
much effort okay and you guys might be
like well hang on a minute downloading
again that's you know two clicks away
like that's easy but no really it's not
because when I'm voting for games and
love them day like I do like every time
I do it I'm going through like I'm
trying to go through as many games as
possible right I want to I want to write
as many games I want to play as many
games as I can in a short amount of time
when I so what I typically tend to do is
basically skip the games that require me
to download it okay I want to just be
able to click be taken to a web page
have it load in two seconds and play the
damn game that's what I want to be able
to do now it's written in C++ I have to
download it I might be missing dll's
that there's all this other stuff
happening okay and that's a bit of a
problem to me okay
so you know in order for if you're
golden light up there again is to finish
a game and have people play it then I
recommend that you choose a language
that supports web browser compatibility
okay that will run inside a web browser
so that people can go to a website and
play the game right on that page Sothis
plus unfortunately does not support that
now there's also not no hot no hot
swapping of code what that means is and
again yes I realize
ways around that for example you could
you could write your important values
into a file and then simply modify the
file here ctrl s hit something in the
game to reload the file and then load
those values in that's very complicated
and that will take time to develop
that's a bit of an engine feature you'll
probably have to develop yourself as
well it's very hot you can't update on
the fly write in Java for example and in
c-sharp you can write you can write a
bit of code you can you can run the
application and then let's just say
you're trying to position a rectangle
you can update the coordinates of the
rectangle hit ctrl s and it will
automatically update it again ok now
because if I suppose is native and must
be compiled that's not possible you
actually have to recompile and rerun
that application that's going to take
time ok and when you have 30 hours of
development time that might be a problem
now there are slow compile time this
isn't a huge this is not a huge issue ok
I put this in here but it's not a
massive issue right um I mean it
certainly is a lot slower to compile C++
in largest scenarios but if you are
using libraries and game engines
especially if you if you're not running
your own engine but you're using really
readily available engines compile times
might slow you down a cab I've seen
compile times be up to like 30 20 to 30
seconds ok and that's a problem because
you know if you're trying to position if
you're trying to position your HUD in
the right in your heads-up display in
the right position on the screen you
have to recompile it all the time
because of the hot swapping that's a
problem ok for 30 hours slow to optimize
right to get so if we're supposed to
actually run fast you need to spend a
lot of time doing memory management and
other garbage collecting things yourself
C++ is a very is probably the fastest
language will actually say it's probably
a bit fast and once you optimize it but
surplus plus is one of the fastest
languages available it's a native
language some wonderful language but to
get it to run at its peak you need to
pour hours into it ok and that's a
problem in love them dear finally it's
slow to develop right because of all
these features no hot swapping slow
compile time starter optimize it's just
going to take you longer to make a game
unfortunately and also there's no real
good inbuilt library okay there's you'll
have to download something like STL if
you want to get a win demographics on
the screen and with relative ease and
that's a bit of a problem again for love
there because we're trying to be as fast
as we can here honestly but yeah I mean
essentially the deal here is c++ is
going to take you it's going to take you
a while to pump out a game in c++
honestly I mean C++ does even have
features for loading images or audio for
example and most of these like SD l SD l
c even SD l needs external libraries
like that like a JPEG and PNG you know
decryption decompression whatever
libraries as well which is a bit of a
bit of a pain to try and set up and so
us so essentially it's a pulse class as
wonderful as it is and I really do love
C++ it's not it's it's going to be slow
to develop a game in C++
now Java let's move out Java so Java
runs a virtual machine ok so instead of
and I'm going to talk about this in
depth here but instead of you compiling
your code and then running the
application the application communicates
directly to the CPU Java doesn't work
that way Java you compile your
application you are you run your
application the application communicates
to the virtual machine which then
communicates to the CPU ok so there's
there's like a little uh there's a
little like pit stop on the way and
because of that pit stop it stops take
time ok it's going to slow your game
down a bit now now this is really
important to utilize this without the
optimization in C++ Java is faster than
C++ ok if you don't handle your memory
with advanced little algorithms whatever
if you don't run C++ if you're in poor
Al's into that and optimize it to the
max Java will be faster ok and because
we don't have this time right because we
don't have all this time to optimize it
in the end I'm going to say that
performance the performance advantage of
C++ is actually going to be irrelevant
right now I'm get a point that I just
brought up there about Java was it it
has an excellent included library with a
great graphics API ok it has one of the
best I in my opinion in my opinion the
best library that comes with any
programming language out there
okay you have an awesome graphics API
the graphics class on Java and that
whole canvas jframe system is just it's
superb okay it is wonderful to doing
graphics and the graphics API as well is
just well that's what I just talked
about but yeah it's just brilliant okay
and that makes making games from scratch
using that API just really fast really
fast okay it's awesome okay now if
that's what you think if you don't make
it from scratch there are solid
libraries available like l w GL okay
that's more than just an OpenGL binding
Jo GL will be an OpenGL by and he must
think that's all that is Java OGL Java
OpenGL but El Topo Gigio lightweight
Java game library was actually what was
used to make Minecraft and that features
a lot of things such as input handling
obviously the window and OpenGL contacts
as well as OpenGL and then you've got
other awesome things like input like
input as in a like joystick and uhm
controller handling and you've got all
these little things that are just
awesome image loading everything
l-dopa jgl is awesome okay um now again
it doesn't you think there are solid
game engines available J monkey ang
enjoy yoga Idol 3d I forgot that little
bracket at the end of that damn it solid
game engines you've got a lot of them
again you got not as much I'd say
surplus plus but because you have LW jgl
available that's awesome and because the
graphics API is amazing it's you know
you might not want to write your own
game engine I mean as in you might want
to write your own game image and you
might not want to use someone else's now
the big plus of Java again is native web
browser compatibility okay appellants
you can run your game inside a web
browser natively okay
and by natively I mean out of the box
you are at once you really don't need to
change much you need to make it execute
as an applet which is about 20 level for
like five lines of code probably and
you'll be able to get your games running
a web browser which means more people
will play it simple as that
okay now hot swapping okay these are
Java this really Java is all pros as far
as it comes to let them dare seriously
you guys heart swapping you can edit
stuff on the fly you want to move that
sure just hundred a new value hit
control s don't you have to close a game
and recompile it it will happen
immediately okay awesome
faster compile in fact it's pretty much
live to compile fast to optimize okay
what I mean by that is that the
optimization in Java because it's a
fairly high-level language when you're
optimizing it you really don't have to
do much okay by optimizing you probably
be spending more times on more time on
how you want to loop through arrays what
you want to do in for loops rather than
memory management because Java handles
memory for you again a blessing in the
curse in litem there it's a blessing
it's a very big blessing and because of
all these features it is extremely fast
as developer game in Java versus C++ now
c-sharp I have not used a lot of c-sharp
okay so I can't really comment much on
this now it's pretty much the same as
gel okay so it's a virtual machine etc
similar graphics API ok it's good a
similar graphics API I haven't
personally used it but I'm aware that it
is very similar to Java as one now it's
ok there's no web browser compatibility
natively I'm we're very well aware you
can run c-sharp in a browser
not natively that's not as much of a
problem as it is with C++ but it is
still more of a problem than it is with
Java there are there are less libraries
available personally the OpenGL binding
for c-sharp I'm not a big fan of that I
have used that by the way I'm not a huge
fan of it I just don't think it's as
strong as it is for say plus spot well
obviously is going to be strong for C++
because it was written for C but it's
not as strong as it is for Java and but
you do have unity again you can develop
with JavaScript or unity on language
also sharp and unity ok so you do have
that option available to you if you know
c-sharp and I might have to say you you
might want to take advantage of that
because we'll talk about libraries in
the next in the next little tip episode
thing but it is very important to you
know to use those little tools
ActionScript so flash right Adobe Flash
um so fast it often time
I obviously flash runs inside a web
browser you can run it on desktop you
cannot inside a web browser and I have
to say it's probably one of the best
excluding html5 it's probably the best
thing you can run in a web browser
nowadays all right I'm going to be
honest with you guys it it's yeah it's
it's really really really do
Java's applets aren't the best nowhere
near the best job is applets suck i'll
probably going to say but they do work
they do do the job they are annoying
ActionScript flash is awesome in a web
browser it's pretty much made for
graphics awesome for graphics right you
can use adobe flash if you have Adobe
Flash Professional whatever cs6 cs5
whatever you have the Adobe Creative
Suite Adobe Flash is an awesome
application you can make some really
sick graphics right in there and then
you know basically it's more it's almost
like using a game engine I'm going to be
honest it's almost like using something
like like unity or something like that
but mainly for 2d games and you know if
when you draw something you can really
smooth it you can add all those effects
onto it it's just really really cool if
you want to make a nice sleek looking
game again live debugging as well as a
feature of that you can debug your code
while it's running okay so that brings
me to my last point here choose what you
know okay
faster development is usually better
okay this is love and air you have 30
hours
I probably stopped saying 30 hours
because I think people might be pulling
the all-nighters and having like I don't
know their girlfriends deliver them
freaking meals-on-wheels here or
something during the day that'd be
awesome actually should get I should get
on that but um a faster development is
usually better okay so you have a
limited amount of time two days to make
a game you want to be able to not spend
time on doing things that are just I
guess burdens on the language okay if if
your goal for lot of day is to complete
a game choose something you're familiar
with if you don't know any C++ but
you've wanted to learn it for the past
two years la time there is probably it's
an awesome place to learn C++ okay I'm
gonna be honest with you but if you're
if you want to complete a game and you
want to submit it I'm gonna go ahead and
say don't do that okay if you just want
to basically spend two days trying to
make a game in year and really care
about submitting it then um you know
then go ahead do something new which is
actually the next point right learn
something new but um if you do want to
complete a game please make sure you do
something that you already understand
because otherwise it's going to
frustrate the hell out of you it's
really hard to do
something you enlightened there because
apart from the pressure we're having to
finish something in two days you know
you also have the pressure to learn
something in two days so just be aware
of that all right so that's that's
pretty much gonna wrap up this video
guys hope you guys enjoyed if you like
these kind of format format of videos
where I just got like presentation
presentation slides in front I mean I'm
just talking
I'll let me know because then they're
not they're not too difficult to make
and and there's a lot of fun as well but
um
apart from that guys please hit the like
button if you did enjoy this video
there'll be another tip fall on them day
tomorrow gonna talk about libraries and
and also happy 19th birthday me goodbye